7,8 du 16 mai jafar lamrini montfort à
vous vous êtes écrivain vous résidez aux
chaînés c'est votre ouvrage l'olivier
ardent qui va nous intéresser à présent
cet ouvrage le voici aux éditions el
naffati les questions de vous de votre
enfance de votre parcours également
alors que vous avez perdu votre père à
l'âge de 10 ans et la première question
que j'ai envie de vous poser c'est
pourquoi ce choix d'avoir écrit à la
troisième personne à aucun moment même
si vous parlez de vous de votre histoire
de votre famille vous ne dites jeu est
toujours question de il
oui justement c'était pour prendre plus
de liberté par rapport au personnage la
distance parce que voilà il ya une
partie du roman que je voulais
recommencer sa partie que je n'ai pas
vécu directement au maroc la partie qui
concerne votre père parce qu'ils vivent
au maroc et non qu'il ne vient en france
et que vous mettiez en france exactement
donc
la troisième personne me permettait de
prendre de la distance et donc
d'exprimer beaucoup plus librement
beaucoup plus objectivement mon vécu le
vécu de mes parents et tout de même un
passage un passage vous parlez
directement c'est au tout début c'est
pour la dédicace du livre voilà va papa
voilà ce qu'on m'a raconté de toi est ce
qu'il me reste de souvenirs c'est le
seul moment où clairement on sent que
c'est vous qui vous qui vous exprimer
vous nous dites un ce livre c'est un
hommage à votre père vous parler de ses
premières années au maroc de son choix
de venir en france pour sa famille pour
offrir autre chose à sa famille mais
tout s'est pas passé forcément dans
meilleur des mondes
oui oui donc il y avait le rêve européen
après il ya eu la désillusion rencontrer
notamment lorsqu'ils sont arrivés dans
une cité et le métier très difficile
d'ouvriers dans les années 60 c'était
beaucoup plus compliqué qu aujourd'hui
l'ouvrier des témoins - protégez moi
dans un cocon donc l'hiver a été très
mal vécue par cette population donc j'ai
beaucoup d'histoires à ce niveau là j'en
ai parlé dans le livre et il est temps
que je trouvais intéressant d'en parler
c'est d'une certaine manière toutes ces
difficultés au quotidien ce qui a fait
votre père en fait oui il a eu un métier
très difficile notamment et un passage
au juste écrit ou où il travaillait
justement par hasard de voir ma cité et
de loin je l'avais reconnu sa silhouette
et je m'étais rapproché de lui pour voir
et là j'ai vu vraiment la difficulté de
de son travail
avec la pioche les pelles hextadon je
suis resté de nombreuses heures à
l'observer et j'étais vraiment touchée
et je comprenais mieux pourquoi quand
ils rentrent le soir ils pouvaient pas
trop nous parler pourquoi il était très
fatigué et c'est donc oui hélas hélas
malheureusement pas dépasser les 55 ans
donc malade lorsque vous avez à peu près
cinq ans exactement cinq ans plus tard
il décède
oui forcément c'est un événement
traumatisant pour un enfant pour toute
une famille on aurait pu penser que ça
entraînerait des difficultés mais ça
peut être le cas pour vous ça a été
l'effet inverse
vous êtes devenu premier de la classe et
vous l'êtes rester maintenant vous êtes
ingénieur
parce que là vous écrivez s'était mis
notre premier ouvrage mais vous êtes
aussi devenu ingénieur de longues études
et toujours été premier de la classe à
partir de ce jour oui ça a été vraiment
un déclic parce que j'étais j'étais
mauvais niveau en primaire et puis après
le décès de mon père je me suis
retrouvée pratiquement du jour au
lendemain un premier au collège au lycée
ensuite j'ai fait une prépa parisienne
prestigieuse et une grande école a une
haute idée tout en étant chef de famille
face à lui être difficile aussi pour
vous comment vous avez vécu ces années
oui c'était difficile et je n'ai pas
vraiment eu d'enfance parce que à partir
de 5 ans il ya eu la maladie et puis
après le décès etc
j'ai ensuite dû m'occuper de mes petits
frères et soeurs pour les encadrer pour
leurs études etc
donc oui c'était compliqué j'en parle
bien dans le livre aimé mais ça m'a
renforcé et puis voilà je les résultats
étaient là à la fin et donc je trouve
que voilà le sens sort grandie donc ce
qui vous intéresse particulièrement dans
ce livre c'est pas de raconter forcément
votre histoire c'est d'arriver à l
épilogue à la conclusion on va s'y
attarder un petit peu parce quand on a
discuté avant que vous ne passiez sur ce
plateau vous m'avez dit vous avez
construit le livre pour la conclusion
pour les pilotes
cette discussion en fait que vous
retranscrivez en étant donc un témoin un
petit peu extérieur puisque vous
utilisez la troisième personne avec
votre mère oui c'était très important
pour moi parce que donc cet épilogue
traite de la question de l'éducation
dans les familles issues de
l'immigration
et comme dans l'édition de la religion
dans la religion et comme je les dis on
demande à ces jeunes en fait deux quand
ils sortent de chez eux et qu'ils se
rendre en espace public de faire un
voyage permanent de 400 ans parce que
c'est des populations qui sont qui sont
issus de lieux qui était en marche sans
eau courante électricité sans école et
donc avec candiac à certains archaïsmes
entrée qui l'ont gardé que l'on
transposé en venant s'installer en
europe en france c'est pas de leur faute
ça a fait et donc on demande à ces
jeunes de traverser quatre cents à
chaque fois lorsqu'ils rentrent chez eux
ou qu'ils se rendent dans l'espace
public donc c'est très difficile c'est
pour ça que j'aimais pas de jugement sur
les jeunes qui font qu'ils ont des
difficultés à s'intégrer parce que voilà
je suis passé par là je j'ai eu vraiment
les différentes étapes à sion monthey et
cet épilogue
voilà je parle de l'amour que j'ai pour
mes parents du sacrifice ils ont
effectué pour moi donc je veux le témoin
je suis reconnaissant et les pilotes
montre que à partir d'un certain moment
il faut passer à un autre cycle et voilà
saint céré pleinement dans la république
française avec les valeurs françaises
kita
comment dire à faire preuve d' un truc
guillemets de rébellion vis-à-vis de ses
parts parce que c'est le cas vis-à-vis
de votre mère lorsqu'il ya eu cette
conversation que vous l'avez expliqué
donc tout le chemin que vous aviez fait
le cheminement vous aviez fait toutes
les cultures qu avec lesquels vous aviez
pu échanger
vous avez des mots très durs le livre
donc là il s'agit du coran ne tolère pas
d'autre façon de penser ni d'autres
libertés que celles qui sont écrites ça
forcément votre mère l'a difficilement
acceptée elle a peut-être passer le
temps et le camp je le connais mieux
qu'elle parce que je les lui et le coran
et n'est pas très connue en fait dans la
population maghrébine
parce que c'est un arabe très ancien et
c'est donc n'est pas connu par ses gens
et nous on a essayé de nous les jeunes
en france on a créé au coran bien les
traductions en français donc je les lui
et c'est vrai que c'est pas un texte en
iran c'est un texte
on a à peu près plus de la moitié des
versets qui sont contre contre ce qui
est nôtre ce n'est pas votre cas mr à sa
réponse est ce que vous retranscris vais
vous allez me dire si c'est
véritablement les mots quels employés
mais c'est l'enfer qui t'attend j'étais
une mauvaise mère oui c'est ce que je
dis c'est ce que timmer sks dit toutes
les autres maires aussi que dans ce
genre de famille quand on s'éloigne du
religieux con con quand on accepte de
de dire avec courage que on est athée
quand on n'est pas croyant en fait aux
objectifs avec ce livre c'est quoi c'est
de montrer aussi aux plus jeunes aux
jeunes de votre âge que qu'on peut ce
qu'il faut peut-être même ce coupé 2 2
la religion en tout cas avoir son propre
cheminement son propre cheminement pas
nécessairement se couper de la religion
de m'avoir sa réfection
et voilà deux ans que le lien avec les
parents est sacré dans cette culture et
je trouve que c'est assez dangereux
parce qu'il faut avoir un esprit
critique c'est ce qu'on entend dans
l'école française depuis
depuis je suis tout petit ont on parle
d'esprit critique
donc je comprends pas prendre le mettrai
pas en application avec cette autorité
par exemple n'avait pas l'impression
justement avec le message que vous
cessiez de véhicules et c'est encore
plus difficile aujourd'hui qu'il ya des
difficultés dans la société à faire
passer ce message on a l'impression
qu'elle que soit la communauté pas
forcément avec avec l'islam mais quelle
que soit la commune aucune communauté
chacun se replie sur ses propres
certitudes la recherche de la vérité du
juste c'est le sens qu'on doit suivre en
permanence
donc à partir du moment où nous oppose
le dog ou de la noire c'est parce que
l'obscurantisme excédera il faut il faut
s'offusquer il faut se rebeller il faut
pas se laisser faire
fauchon aller de l'avant il faut pas
accepter
donc voilà les en général ça avance ça
se fait dans c'est vrai dans
difficilement débuts dans les premiers
temps mais au bout d'un certain moment
ça passe parce que le juste la vérité
c'est des choses qui permettent de
toujours de gagner toutes les batailles
en fait avec du temps certainement mais
faut aller dans ce sens-là d'olivier
ardent c'est donc à découvrir c'est
votre ouvrage c'était le premier vous
êtes ingénieur mais vous avez décidé
d'en écrire d'autres
oui j'en ai dans d'autres registres
cette fois ci une pièce de théâtre une
fantaisie
une trilogie qui qui est un peu sur le
même mode que les mille et une nuits
donc voilà je continue à écrire c'est
vraiment ma passion première
c'est une autre carrière qui va débuter
pour vous je ne sais pas je l'espère
crois pas tu peux pas à part avoir été
fait des longues études pour être
ingénieur maintenant vous lancer dans
l'écriture l'olivière dans merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur ce plateau nous
en parler et témoigner